now dave roberts taking his team out to
the jackie robinson statue prior to the
game he mentioned the word legacy a big
part of his is that he's the first
minority manager of the dodgers
this man has a legacy because uh what he
had to endure
and now we handle it with grace humility
determination toughness hooks of the
dodgers starter julio urias
back to the beginning of last season you
include the postseason he's 9-0 with a
on 2-6-8 pitches he strikes out hamson
getting him with a high fast wall one
gone
and mcmahon gets a pitch he can drive
high and deep right field
and it is gone home run number six
ryan mcmahon got a curve ball and he got
just enough of it to leave dodger
stadium
what a start for ryan mcmahon in the
opening couple of weeks
in 2021 27 year old austin gomberg check
this out
yeah we know the high walk rate he's one
of two pitchers in baseball to throw at
least nine innings and allow
only two hits his first pitch tonight
is cracked down the line to left hooking
towards the corner
and bouncing off the wall chris taylor
wastes no time with a ringing double
on the first pitch
and said i need you to take that guy
some new nachos
that is muscled into right gaza will
play it in a bounce
taylor had to make sure that it would
drop so he advances to third and they've
got them poured in the blink of an eye
padre club they may get fernando tatis
back this weekend
how about that for a quick recovery
great curveball swung on and missed
talk about dropping it right into that
subaru strike zone
first and third one out pulled to third
to second on the first double play
inning over
no harm done
he wastes no time third k for urias
[Applause]
as the rockies try and build on this one
nothing advantage
3-2 lifted high and deep left field back
at garrett hampson's first of the year
make it two nothing colorado
what an a b for hampson 94 mile an hour
fastball and he struck him out with a 93
mile an hour fastball in the first
inning secures it not this time i got
you i'm going to take it into your
bullpen
[Applause]
15 20 feet toward left center the 1-2
and a strikeout swinging it was dropped
by will smith he'll throw to first
breaking ball and mcmahon was badly
beaten
here's turner
who singled his first time up
turner's fourth to lead the club from
down two nothing to a head 3-2
some flexibility in that diet too boy
there's some x factor right there
stays closed but the hips just open up
and then when the lever system unwinds
it is a missile
to endure all of what he endured a pitch
swing and a miss
austin gomberg got mckinstry with a high
fastball
and that is strikeout number five for
the rockies left-hander
julio aureus is already behind two
strikes
paul egan's an original rocky and
said that curious can go right back and
relax and get ready to do what he does
best that is pitch
he just austin just dropped that thing
right off the table into the subaru
strike zone
strike three top of the zone taylor
tried to be inconspicuous played off
look around knew that was
strike three cranks this ball
top spinning towards the wall off the
base
of the wall and he'll scoot around first
head to second tapia's throw off line
and he's three for three
single homer double for justin turner
smith fought off to right field
and it hangs up for gospel just like
that the rockies have the tying running
scoring position
here in the sixth inning with cj crone
coming up
through one thought he had strike three
somehow crone's still up there wow you
can't throw it any better than that
so you get a rebrief two and two
and that's a bullet to center field the
ball game's going to get tied up
taken advantage is cj crown
and ryan mcmahon comes across 3-3
in la 3-3 in the sixth inning here's the
seven hitter
and this is to right field could drop it
will
and bobbled by mckinstry the rockies
take the lead as crone scores
fuentes to third and now daz is hung up
here goes fuentes to the plate high
throw
he scores daza to second
and he'll pause there colorado taking
advantage of sloppy baseball by la
and they have a two-run lead you can go
to the bullpen
shallow center and the great wheels of
garrett hampson you thought that was
going to drop
but hamson saw it the whole way two on
two out in a two-run game
delmonte has had great success with the
change-up against left-handers tonight i
think
max is going to see a few of them this
crowd almost
trying to will something to happen
high drive right center field
lightning strikes and the badgers lead
three-run home run max muncie
his third of the season and the dodgers
lead at 6'5
the dodgers have the base is loaded with
two gone leading by a run
oh look out this one does get by and
here comes will smith
carlos estevez wildton
they're really protecting these guys
as far as this whole season diving
stopped by rio
city feeds santana
just his second start of the year at
first base
makes a great stop right there
[Applause]
in a tough spot here trevor story
introduced as the pinch hitter
representing the go-ahead run
price with another 02. he's got
back-to-back strikeouts this one with a
change-up
strikes out story strikes out hamson
he's an
out away in on his hands roller to
second
muncie to first david price with his
first career regular season save